hey what's up guys it's rob and welcome
to my tutorial for the easy minute
wallet
today i'm going to show you a quick and
easy way that you can store your cash
and cards if you don't want to carry
around a big bulky wallet like this
it's a cool origami model that's a
modified design by humiaki huzida and it
has
four spots with two inside pockets and
two
outside sleeves that you can store your
cash and cards it's a really thin
sleek design that's simple to make and a
lot of fun to fold
i'm also announcing the launch of my
brand new patreon page
i've always wanted to interact with my
subscribers so now available
on my rob's world patreon page are three
separate tiers that you can join where
you can get shout outs on my channel
join live sessions and discord chats or
get one-on-one
extra help sessions you can sign up now
to join a community and show your
support and get the inside scoop also on
new ideas like this duct tape hat that i
made
i might even use your ideas for new
videos on my channel i'll post a link in
the video and also the description so be
sure to check it out
to make the wallet we'll need a letter
size or a4 paper of any color
and you can also use cardstock if you
want the wallet to be extra sturdy
once you have the paper let's jump right
into it hold the paper with the longer
edges up and down and take the top and
fold
it down to the bottom line up the edges
and make a nice sharp crease
on top then you can unfold the paper
and we're going to take the top and
bottom edges folding it into that new
crease that we made
fold the top down and make a crease and
then fold the bottom edge
directly next to the top edge in the
middle and make a crease on the bottom
once again unfold the edges we're going
to take the top edge and fold it down
about half of an inch or the width of
your pinky
take a small portion of the top and just
fold it inwards like this
and make a nice sharp crease on top so
that it looks like this
do the same on the bottom folding it
about half of an inch
once you've done that make a nice sharp
crease on the bottom
now we can take the two top corners and
fold them inwards to this first line
right here
airplane fold it in like this and make a
nice sharp crease on the top
so that it looks like that do the same
on the top left
folding the top corner inwards and
creasing now we could flip it around and
do the same on the other side
airplane fold the two top corners
inwards and
make a nice sharp crease on top now we
can take the top and bottom and fold
them
on this crease right here fold it and
flatten it and then fold the top edge in
and flatten it as well once it's nice
and flat i'm going to turn it to the
left like this
and pick it up you'll see these two
corners here i'm going to press on them
and fold the top edge down along the
corners or a little below them
once it's folded down just make a nice
sharp crease and reinforce it with your
fingernail like this
then you can unfold the edge and do the
same on the other side
press on the corners fold the edge down
and give it a nice sharp crease
then you can unfold the edge and we're
going to fold backwards
on that crease that we just made once we
fold it backwards then we could
flatten it out and press on it now we
could flip the whole thing
upside down and fold backwards on the
top edge here
just like we did on the other side then
you could take the bottom edge and
you'll see
we're going to tuck it underneath this
little triangular pocket
slide it underneath the pocket and do
the same on the other side
just like this so it's underneath now we
could flatten everything out
and we can once again pick it up take
the left edge and fold it across
on this vertical line and make sure it's
nice and flat once again
now we've completed the minute wallet
and you could take the card and slip it
into the left side pocket
take the cash and slip it into the right
just lift the pocket
open like this and tuck it in and you
also have two additional sleeves on the
outside that you can also use
for cards or cash thank you guys so much
for watching my tutorial for the easy
minute wallet i hope you guys enjoyed it
if you did be sure to give it a thumbs
up down below
and also don't forget to subscribe and
click that notification bell
also be sure to check out my patreon
page and let me know down in the
comments below if you want to see
the duct tape hat or whatever you'd like
to see leave a comment on here
i'd love to start a new community on my
patreon page and connect with you guys
and do live sessions i think it would be
a lot of fun
i got a lot of new ideas coming up so if
you're not subscribed be sure to click
that notification bell and i'll see you
guys soon